and his verification is for 100 million
dollars liquid plus
and so the guy has over 100 million
dollars
and he did it all through
two or three of these apps and i believe
with close to no employees and he did it
over around like eight or ten years
[Music]
we have a friend who it seems like might
get rich very quickly
here let me explain richer
they
created a product or a service or an app
and
they every day they're posting a chart
of like the growth of this thing and
it's like an early version of a hockey
stick it's like yep we went from doing a
hundred dollars a day 500 a day thousand
dollars a day today three thousand
dollars a day today's gonna be nine
thousand dollars a day pretty quickly
like you know fast forward two weeks
this person's gonna put a chart in there
that's gonna show them doing 200 000 in
revenue just today and it's gonna be
nothing has changed it's just they just
let the growth carry on and you see that
you're like wow
that's that's winning like that's the
hov lane that's the fast lane where you
could just go in and you could win
faster like jeez i didn't realize that i
thought i gotta
bust my ass for 10 years and the reality
is this person has been busting their
ass for 10 years building up the skills
so that they can launch a new product
and they can do let's call it five to
ten million this year
in in potential profits now
this person if you remember
uh many months ago and they told me they
told us this exact this exact thing they
go
yeah i'm just thinking about ideas that
can make i forgot what they said 10 or
50 million dollars
i want to make 10 million dollars in a
year 50 million dollars in a year
and i was like okay like you know
yeah sure you know and i want jessica
alba to you know add me on snapchat
right now like but it's not necessarily
going to happen like you could just say
it but he was like no i've been studying
there's apps that do that in the app
store
and he's like showing us give me two
examples yeah
yeah just showing your screenshots and
examples it's like that does that yeah
this does that yeah and you now you see
10 of them and all of a sudden
first of all i never knew somebody who
even stated a goal like that so just
hearing it for the first time was like
that's interesting i knew people that
would say
i want to build a huge company a billion
dollar company that was normal i'd heard
that before i'd heard i want to get a
high paying job you know i want to make
you know 500k a year at this company
i've heard that before i never really
heard somebody be like i'm looking for a
way that i can make 10 million dollars
in three months that was actually the
exact thing it was how do i make 10
million dollars in three months
and so i was like all right well
never heard that that was new then i
thought well my brain doesn't come up
with any examples of how to do that
that's like you know doesn't involve you
know putting a ski mask on and walking
into a wells fargo so like
you know
and then he gave me 10 examples and so
it's like okay well now i got 10
examples number 11 doesn't seem so
far-fetched at that point
and i remember coming to talking to you
and being like dude
have you heard anybody think like this
talk like this come up with ideas like
this because i believe that there's
great power in questions and i never
really heard somebody ask the question
how do i make 10 million dollars in the
next three months and once that question
was asked now my brain has to start
coming up with answers and at first my
brain was struggling
and then as he gave me examples it
started to get better and better and
better and come up with examples about
how you might do that and now it's
literally happening like that right now
scenario is actually playing out right
in front of us what do you think of this
i think it's awesome i think i think
it's still too early i think anything
that comes fast will go away fast or can
go away fast
but he called his shot and we are seeing
on a daily basis whether it's com it's
coming it is in fact now coming into
reality and i think it's awesome i think
that there's
ways
i think peter thiel said it where he's
like what's your five-year goal and then
someone says their goal and he says cool
how can you do that in six months
so i usually believe in that this guy
took it even further which is what your
five year goal do it in three months and
it's awesome and there's another guy who
i know that's done this and he's public
his name is alan wong do you have the uh
the the app on your iphone that lets you
listen to police scanners it's like the
police scanner app
no but i know i know of these apps these
are it's like they're weird yeah it's
like 5-0
radio app i think like 5-0 radio app and
this this guy alan wong he posted in
reddit in 2013 and he basically said um
uh
he said hey i'm alan wong i was told to
create name here have it up here
yeah you wanna you wanna read it or you
read it up here he goes yeah he goes
i'ma
ask me anything i'm a person in his 20s
who went from rags to vicious during the
recession he goes how i did it i develop
apps my most popular app is called the
5.0 radio police scanner it lets you
listen to police chatter around the
world you've probably seen this used in
the latest spider-man movie although
they rebranded it uh and as of 2012 my
apps have been downloaded by 20 million
people by the way this is 10 years ago
he wrote this so he did this in the
2008. i have an update on it that i can
give you in a second so so he goes my
parents were raised in the slums of
china they fled here with my brother to
new york my mother worked in a sweatshop
in chinatown before she quit became a
homemaker my father was a herbalist
before he passed away unnaturally three
months after i graduated from college
after his passing no one in my family
had a job
and so he says i found a full-time job
at columbia university i was the only
one with income so i taught myself how
to create apps in my free time and i
created apps on the weekends with hopes
of making some side income i didn't
expect this to make me millions
and then he says what does he say is
money i don't think he says his money
somewhere here but uh yeah go ahead fill
in the gaps so he doesn't say it there
but i found it so there's this other
subreddit that i talk about all the time
called fat fire and they've got this
particular type of flare called verified
by the mods where the mods the
moderators
look at the income or your balance sheet
they look at something and they say yeah
we believe it what you are saying is
true and his verification is for a
hundred million dollars liquid plus
and so the guy has over 100 million
dollars
and he did it all through
two or three of these apps and i believe
with close to no employees and he did it
over around like eight or ten years
it says he by the way he says
so he has three apps he has 5-0 radio
then he has police scanner plus
and then he has one more called what is
it called
um
hang on he's got three apps
that were in the top
like the top hundred so so he goes
this means i'm the only person ever in
app store history this is what he wrote
at the time this was back in i don't
know 2012 2013 something like that
i'm the only person in history to have
in the in the app at to have three apps
in the app store that were top 10
overall in the paid and free categories
at the same time yeah man this guy's
cool and then he if you google his
username it's rego apps so r-e-g-o apps
and then fat fire you'll see his posts
from fat fire and he talks about uh what
it's like to be uh different tiers of
rich and he has all types of of like you
know when i was at this thing this is
how i felt when i was at this other
thing this is how i felt and now
according to his flair it's over a
hundred million it's a this is a so
you're asking who else do i know that's
done this i don't know this guy and i
can't verify that any of this is true
but it's pretty interesting and it might
be true well yeah and i don't know the
speed that this guy did it but um still
amazing by the way we should get
verified in fat fire why aren't we
posting in fat fire that seems like a
that's our those are our people we
should hang out i do post there i post
there under a name that no one knows me
as but i would post there more would you
po do do uh
you use this
yeah i'll go browse i never post never
comment but i'll i'll make an account
and i'll uh let's do it let's get
verified let's do an ama there yeah so
look this guy's thing says i fat f i
found his username he was i fat fired at
age 25 i make 10 million dollars a year
in my 30s 10 yeah 10 million plus a year
in my 30s and i have over 100 million
dollars according to which has been
verified for the mods and here this is
what he says someone says what's the
difference in millionaires or in money
levels he goes at 100k to a million you
can tip very generously and be okay with
that at one to five million you could
fund some medical expenses and maybe a
college college tuition or two maybe for
an extended family member or friend at
five to twenty you could pay off a
handful of college tuition i guess
they're asking about donation you can
pay off a handful of college tuitions
and some expensive surgeries and then he
jumps to uh 50 to 50 million you can
create several nonprofits and overseas
that uh that are overseas and help
people uh at a community level like
building a school or local community or
something so he like talks about this
constantly throughout this subreddit and
it's very very interesting
[Music]
you